This video is made possible by Nord VPN. If you're online,
you really should be using a VPN. And that's where Nord VPN comes in.
I know it's tempting.
Not to bother and hope for the best,
but really those stories you've read about people having their data stolen do
happen. And you don't want to make it easy for anyone to do that.
But using a VPN offers more than just security. For example,
Nord VPN lets you access any of its thousands of servers and different countries
all around the globe. So if you've had the end of your Netflix queue,
simply try changing the location of your server and get access to content
libraries that due to licensing agreements are only available in specific
geographic locations. For example,
most of European countries have strong licensing agreements restricting which
soccer matches can be viewed depending on the location of the viewer with Nord
VPN, you can change your country without even moving from your sofa.
It's also a great gift for the ones you care about.
Especially as family members are depending more and more on the internet to stay
connected while they are social destination with North VPN,
you can stay safe virtually as well. Nord VPN is super fast.
So watching video as a breeze, no lag whatsoever,
if you've ever used VPNs and thought they were slow, well,
no more with Nord VPN and you can use it on all your devices. Very,
very easily Android Chrome windows, Linux,
and on up to six different devices on just one account.
Also there are no logs kept at all.
Unlike companies based in the EU or the U S Northern VPN is based in Panama.
So they don't have to keep logs at all, which is great for your privacy.
So take control of your internet experience right now with Nord VPN special
black Friday deal. Every purchase of a two-year plan gets you 68% off,
plus an additional four months free go to Nord vpm.com/visual politic,
or use the code visual politic at checkout.
It's a risk-free with Nords 30 day money back.
Let's get cracking
[inaudible].
From Hong Kong to the Sino Indian border throughout the South China sea and up
to the Senkaku islands and the East China sea,
the Chinese giant has been proving itself to be a strict and insatiable
superpower with its neighbors for months. Making it clear that from now on,
it wants to be the one pulling the strings of power entry and politics,
and this region of the world in order to do so as not hesitated to antagonize
practically all of its neighbors. During the last two years alone,
China has had clashes with Malaysia, the Philippines, Vietnam, South Korea,
Brunei, Japan, and Hong Kong, and all of this without counting the coronavirus,
the trade war with the United States or the diplomatic clash with Australia.
And of course, Taiwan has been no exception.
The relationship between the people's Republic of China and Taiwan is also going
through one of its most tense periods in recent decades.
During the last few months, we have seen economic threats,
large-scale military maneuvers,
an active campaign of political pressure to exclude Taiwan from international
institutions and also a recurrent violation of Taiwanese airspace and waters by
the people's liberation army,
which is the formal name of the armed forces of the people's Republic of China.
And all of this has brought some key questions to the table.
How can Taiwan be defended?
Would it be possible to protect the Island from a possible invasion of what is
happening in Taiwan? You want to know more.
Listen up.
It's a threat of the red dragon.
The communist party of China claims Taiwan full sovereignty over the small
prosperous and democratic country of 24 million inhabitants.
As we have told you on other occasions they have been doing so since the
politics of this Island separated from those of mainland China in 1940,
Over the last few decades,
Beijing thought that the growing economic and social ties that have been forged
since the Chinese economy opened up to the world would facilitate the future
peaceful integration of Taiwan under some special model.
Like the one that has existed for years in Hong Kong,
following the doctrine of one country, two systems, however, freedom,
democracy and openness to the West have fueled the opposite sentiment today.
At least two thirds of Taiwanese people no longer identify themselves as
Chinese, but simply as Taiwanese, likewise,
more than 60% of the population has a negative image of mainland China,
especially of course of its government and political system.
Taiwan is less and less Chinese possession certainly shared by president Tsai.
Ing-wen herself. Of course,
the bad news is that China has never given up what it considers to be legitimate
rate to reunify Taiwan with the mainland,
even if it means resorting to force G Zhang Peng have self has clearly defended
by DIA and take note because the deadline they are considering in Beijing is
2049 when they will celebrate the 100th anniversary of the company.
Just revolution.
What once might have been a remote possibility has no, perhaps become a,
not so improbable threat.
The G Jang Penn government,
perhaps as a way of politically compensating for the economic slowdown that
China has experienced in recent years has set in motion, a nationalist agenda.
The likes of which has not been seen for decades.
China is doubling down on its territorial claims and that's causing conflict
across Asia, CNN,
China taking on more conflict around the world from remote Himalayan valleys to
small tropical islands and Western capitals, and increasingly assertive.
China is taking on conflicts around the world, like never before,
as the United States retreats, Bangkok post.
Let's put it this way.
No sooner is China out of one fight than it is already in another.
And now given the coronavirus crisis, things could be even worse.
You know what better way is there to divert attention than to start a
confrontation where national pride itself as its stake.
But do you want some concrete examples here? Well, take the South China sea,
I see dotted with small islands reefs and sun banks that is also crucial for
world trade. Some of the world's busiest shipping routes pass through here,
practically a third of all global maritime trees. Well look at the way,
things are.
Chinese.
Argues that practically all of the sea belongs to China,
that it is part of its territorial waters as had no qualms about confronting at
least five other countries regarding this claim, the Philippines, Vietnam,
Malaysia, Indonesia, and Brunei. And not only that to protect its claims.
Jaina has been building artificial islands on reefs and sun banks since 2014,
strongly to artificial islands on which airstrips Michele launching systems and
air defenses have been installed. Of course,
the disapproval of the Chinese government by the international community has
made a virtually.
New difference.
A little further North and the East China sea.
It maintains a territorial confrontation with the government of Japan over the
Senkaku islands, a chain of Rocky and uninhabited islands,
which have nevertheless caused situations of great tension.
Also during the summer of 2020,
there was a clash between Chinese and Indian soldiers in the Himalayas.
The event did not go beyond a brawl,
but we are talking about a B-roll that resulted in 20 casualties among Indian
soldiers,
according to new Delhi and the occupation of about 40 kilometers squared of his
territory on the border with China and in Hong Kong. What can we say about.
Hong Kong?
China has forcibly imposed a new security law that is basically ending freedom
of expression and political participation.
And what had been one of the freest places in the world for almost 70 years and
my friends, we must keep one thing in mind here.
It might be hard for us to imagine,
but what we have seen in Hong Kong has been something like the equivalent of
what it may have meant. If Warsaw pack troops had occupied West Berlin,
China has sidestepped international agreements,
the political regime that existed in the city state and the civil liberties of
the Hong Kong people with impunity.
[Inaudible].
All this. We have to add the trade war with the United States,
the imposition of punitive tariffs against Australia,
the persecution of local minorities as is the case with the weekers.
And of course the acts of pressure against Taiwan during 2020,
China had put its strategy of harassment and demolition into fifth gear.
The Chinese army has staged some of its largest air and Naval maneuvers,
and a long time around Taiwan, including some exercises.
The official Chinese press itself described as a real invasion drill.
In addition,
China has not hesitated to violate Taiwanese airspace on repeated occasions,
having their fighters and bombers crossed the so-called meddling,
the border of the device,
the waters of the Taiwan Strait between the two countries.
We are talking about dozens and dozens of cases. During 2020 alone,
You see my friends for almost 60 years,
the Chinese threat to Taiwan seemed more bravado than a real possibility. Why?
Because although the Taiwanese army was much smaller,
it has traditionally been much, much better armed as far superior technology,
better training and the support of the United States whose fleet to control to
the region. However, in the last 15 years, everything has changed.
China is executing a huge program of modernization of its armed forces.
To give you an idea.
Their air force currently has more fourth generation aircraft than all of the
planes of the Taiwanese air force is commissioning aircraft carriers,
destroyers and vessels with amphibious transport capacity.
It has developed more than 1000 short range.
Ballistic missiles aimed directly at Taiwan is continuously conducting maneuvers
around the Island and even has an it division whose mission is to launch cyber
attacks against strategic Taiwanese elements and be prepared to freeze their
communications and key infrastructure if necessary. So for the first time,
the idea of a Chinese invasion does not seem so far fetched.
Our concern is whether in times of war,
our command and control systems can function without hindrance,
whether the country could still be under effective command,
wanting you deputy of the ruling democratic progressive party and the chairman
of the defense committee.
And of course at this point, many of you are probably thinking,
but grant the United States remains committed to the defense of Taiwan and yes,
that's true, but the problem is how far does this commitment go?
And is it enough and enormous.
Listen up
strategic ambiguity.
The United States officially cut off his relations with the Republic of China.
And that meant with Taiwan and auditor recognize the people's Republic of China.
By the way,
we have already covered this mess on visual politics videos that we'll link for
you in the description,
the U S Congress approved to the Taiwan relations act a law,
which reaffirms that.
Although the Taiwanese government is not recognized as the legitimate government
of mainland China,
special commitments are maintained with the Island commitments,
such as recognizing any non peaceful Chinese intervention as a threat reserving
the right to come to Taiwan's defense and make available to them.
I E sell them all the weapons they need. Well,
the fact is that from that moment on what came to be known as the policy of
strategic ambiguity was set in motion.
Taiwan.
Acts did not strictly state that the United States would intervene in the event
of aggression, but it did reserve the right to do so.
It was an ambiguous strategy that ultimately paid off on the one hand.
Beijing has never been sure what the us response would be. Therefore,
they can't be sat in the attack on the Island.
Won't lead to a direct war with the American power. On the other hand,
this strategic ambiguity meant the Taiwanese were never quite sure how far USAID
would go. So they had no choice,
but to secure their own defenses while also improving their relations.
With China.
My friends,
the question we really need to ask ourself as how far does the U S commitment
actually go?
Let me explain if the United States government was never able to commit to the
defense of Taiwan when its military superiority was enormous,
will it really do so now with a China that has become a superpower?
This is not a minor question, especially for the Taiwanese, of course
China's growing military power has not only become a threat to Taiwan's defacto
independence,
but also increases the price of U S involvement or conflict with China today
could well become the prelude to world war three.
When the bullets really start flying the American people,
most of whom can't find Taiwan on a map, we'll be hard pressed to say, no,
I'm really willing to trade Los Angeles for Taipei,
Michael Hunziker of George Mason university.
And it's not only that the United States has geography against it. Why?
Because its capacity in the area depends on its Naval fleets and a handful of
Asian basis with end range of Chinese muscles.
And they may not be nimble enough to get there in time. And you know what?
The worst thing is that the same idea,
the suspicion that could be shared by the Chinese government,
but when the time comes, the reaction of the United States will be more,
more than a formal protest as has happened with Hong Kong could fuel the Chinese
intervention. In other words,
this policy of strategic ambiguity could act as a catalyst in this conflict
today.
That is precisely why many voices in Washington are calling for an end to this
policy once. And for all.
We need to make clearer where we stand,
especially by ending any remaining ambiguity about how we'd react to the use of
force and altering our military force structure and posture Elbridge Colby of
former senior Pentagon official and co-author of the Trump administration's
national defense strike.
On the other hand,
it makes it clear that the Taiwanese have to be able to defend themselves at
least for a while, until they can receive help.
But the question is who the hell do you defend yourself against a giant Lake
China and listen up?
[inaudible] sending Taiwan [inaudible] well,
despite all we have seen Taiwan is not a country that goes crazy with its
military budget. Just to give you an idea, the defense spending plan for 2021,
it's about 15.4 billion.
This is approximately between 2.2 and 2.4% of the country's GDP,
depending on what we count or don't count.
It represents an increase of a little more than 10% compared to 2020.
But the truth is that if we look at the last 10 or 20 years,
what we are going to see is that the proportion of military spending has been
reduced. Check this out, curious,
isn't it, of course, at some point,
this downward trend will probably cease to seem so strange to you.
In any case, despite this apparent budgetary restraint. Over the past few years,
the Taiwanese government has continued to close important deals to buy military
equipment from the United States, very advanced military equipment. For example,
in 2019,
it closed a $2 billion acquisition to acquire 108 Abrams
[inaudible] tanks. The American fighting vehicle par excellence.
Then in 2020 president sign and wing has pledged another $8 billion for 66
state-of-the-art F sixteens. These are just two examples.
We have to add missiles, Naval mines,
and a lot of technology and gadgets of all kinked in total,
more than $15 billion committed in the last two years alone.
And they're still pursuing the F 35,
which has been another huge amount of multimillion dollar contracts. And that.
It's not all the time.
Government is also spending billions to boost local production,
helicopter carriers, destroyers, and their own fighters.
They're even developing the rune submarines a cost of over $1 billion per unit.
The first one is expected to enter service in 2025.
What.
Because the truth is that all of this may serve practically no purpose.
Right?
Well, because the difference with China is still enormous. And evidently.
Check this out.
China and Taiwan had practically the same budget at the end of the 1990s today,
the Chinese giants budget is 25 times greater.
And obviously that has a direct reflection on the capabilities of the two
armies.
Look at how the Chinese foreign ministry itself has assessed the increase in
Taiwan's military budget and names for 2021, right?
No matter how much you spend, as we all know, Taiwan is a small Island.
If you want to fight mainland China,
it's like an ant trying to move a tree jowly Xian spokesperson for the Chinese
ministry of foreign affairs.
As you can see the most likely scenario in the event of a Chinese attack,
as many experts have suggested is that in a relatively short time,
a large part of the Taiwanese air force,
most of the Naval force and a lot of key infrastructure would be destroyed,
raised and nailed it. And as if that wasn't enough,
all of the problems don't end there,
it seems that the Taiwanese army that does not participate in international
missions also has a training problem.
Let's just say that it's not hard to find officers who have never actually used
heavy weapons in the field
Matters worse. The shortage of soldiers as another headache,
Taiwan is not exactly a young country,
and there are young people who prepare to devote their lives to other tasks.
Just to give you an idea between 1993 and 2020,
the number of troops in Taiwan's armed forces has been reduced by more than 60%.
It has gone from 500,000 to less than 200,000 soldiers.
What's.
At this point, the question is, how on earth can Taiwan be defended? This,
my friends is the million dollar question
Last video, which I will link for you in the description.
We told you what the political and economic strategy was. Well,
my friends from the defense point of view,
according to most analysts and the Pentagon's own recommendations,
Taiwan could only succeed by completely turning around its military strategy
that is instead of buying expensive military equipment,
that would be practically worthless.
Taiwan has to focus primarily on making the envision such a rescue mission,
but the Chinese would consider it impossible. And in order to do that,
it has to take advantage of its own unique characteristics.
For example, their geography works somewhat in their favor.
Taiwan only has 14 that are considered suitable for Marine invasion.
The rest of the 1,200 kilometers of coastline is protected by reefs rocks.
Cliffs are concrete peers and friends in order to invade,
China would have to carry out the largest landing in history.
So you can already see, it would not be easy at all. In addition,
the terrain is mountainous and the flat areas are either urbanized or flooded
with rice fields,
which makes it serene complicated for large deployments and very conductive to
asymmetric warfare.
And my friends that is the key asymmetric warfare.
Most analysts.
And certainly experts of the Pentagon think that this is the path that Taiwan
should take to recompose.
Their reserves officially made up of 2 million members,
but that when it comes to the crunch, lack training,
train them and prepare them properly acquire many mobile weapons, Naval mines,
cheap and agile systems drones, many drones,
small boats are autonomous of measureables land mains missiles,
modern anti aircraft sets. Them's subterranean operations and supply systems,
radars and missile launch batteries and side mountains, drones,
more drones and myself factories protected from air fire, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera. In short, be prepared to contain the enemy,
to be able to hold out until reinforcements arrive at,
to make things so difficult for the Chinese,
that they will consider it essentially impossible.
We're talking about a strategy that does not require large resources,
which is argued for by experts in Washington and which president site and when
no seems to have decided to implement, to prepare for gorilla warfare.
Unfortunately, however, this does not end the threat.
At least not completely China could try to block it. The Island,
instead of invading it,
it could seek a kind of economic war and it could even establish specific
punishments.
And so now the questions at hand are what should the international community do
to safeguard Taiwan's independence, stand idly by,
as it has done with Hong Kong or mobilize and support of the Island,
if mobilization is chosen, what exactly should be done?
And just how many Chinese bots where we get in the comments leader answers along
with the bots in the comments below as always,
I really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit the Lake if you did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos. Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals and this episode that we're not my dulcet tones.
Finally,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
You want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice. Um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your
favorite podcast.